because every day i say to myself what
am i doing why do you say that
because i can't believe it all happened
to me everything larry king
has died the iconic talk show host was
87 years old
larry leaves behind wife sean king and
three
children cannon chance and larry king jr
larry endured several health issues over
the years
he suffered a heart attack in 1987 and a
stroke in 2019
he also battled prostate and lung cancer
anybody who's had bypass surgery in a
heart attack thinks about mortality a
lot
you what you do is you become pain aware
and every pain you have you relate to
your heart so you try to reduce pain
so what i do is i exercise i eat right i
try to live
fit his death follows one of the most
prolific careers in broadcasting history
i don't come with an agenda i'm not
there to embarrass nor am i there to
praise
i'm there to learn it's all about the
guest and learning about the guests
larry gained national attention for his
radio program the larry king show that
ran between 1978
and 1994. interviewing is something that
just comes naturally with me i had it
since i was eight years old
i interview people socially when i meet
them i'm by nature
a curious elf i'm just interested in
people i listen to their answers and i
ask questions
in 1985 larry king live debuted on cnn
and turned larry into a household name
you know what's great about larry king
he doesn't stop asking you questions and
he listens
from politics to entertainment larry
interviewed countless
influential figures from around the
world
do you want to marry again do you want
to settle down how old are you george
i'm thinking about doing it today
today maybe you got a few girls here i'm
taking numbers
you always know if there's a newsmaker
breaking news
that person will appear on larry king
and larry will ask burt
questions what's driving your husband to
run for president
you know i i've been asking him that
question for years what's wrong with you
no i'm just kidding you know
you got a point though i quit
politicians and celebrities found their
way to larry's desk
right up until the show ended in 2010
is there any boundary you won't cross i
suppose i'll just well you'll have to
wait larry i'm not sure
larry received peabody awards for both
his radio and tv
programs as well as inductions into both
the radio
and broadcasters hall of fame following
the end of larry king live
larry never slowed down hosting programs
such as larry king now
and politicking with larry king oh
look at that look at that oh wow
recently larry also faced tragedy his
son andy and daughter kaya
died within just weeks of each other in
2020
e.t followed larry's incredible journey
through the decades
where he often opened up to us about his
one-of-a-kind career
i have the different stages different
highlights
firstly on the air big highlight because
it was my wish
interviewing eleanor roosevelt when i
was 23 years old that was pretty good
knowing martin luther king
doing frank sinatra for three hours on
the radio has been too many